do you have an Android device and want
to play some Mario on your daily commute
well good news
Super Mario run is coming to Android
devices this week Nintendo of America
have revealed that Super Mario run will
be released for Android alongside the
2.0 point Oh update on March 23 it's a
free download for a sampling of levels
and ten bucks to unlock the full games
six worlds and that's really it but
don't go anywhere here's five
mariya facts that you might not know
sorry for saying it like that I am very
sorry
Super Mario creator Shigeru Miyamoto
gave Mario a hat because he can't draw
here the bushes and clouds in Super
Mario Bros are the same sprite just
color changed to save space Mario wears
overalls to differentiate his arms from
his body so that his early sprite looked
like he was swinging his arms back and
forth as he moved his iconic moustache
came about due to the graphical
limitations on the NES making it
difficult to draw a mouth speaking of
mouths Charles Martin a wasn't always
the voice of mario optimus prime himself
peter cullen voiced mario in the 1983
cartoon series saturday supercade for
up-to-date gaming news as it happens be
sure to subscribe if you're on youtube
and for everything Mario Nintendo and
gaming on the go
keep it locked in to GameSpot